President Trump is dismissing a stunning
new report that says he ordered the
firing of Special Counsel Robert Muller
seven months ago sources tell the New
York Times the president claimed three
conflicts of interest disqualified
Muller from leading the investigation of
Russian election meddling the report
confirmed by the Washington Post as
White House Counsel Donal McGann refused
to go along and the president then
changed his mind this adds a new layer
of intrigue to the special counsels
expected interview of the president in
the next few weeks major Garrett is at
the White House major good morning good
morning here's the bottom line
last summer prominent White House
officials argued against President Trump
taking any punitive action against
Special Counsel Robert Muller and they
prevailed 42 hundred miles from the
White House President Trump addressed
the controversy from Davos The New York
Times says when President Trump tried to
fire Special Counsel Robert Muller in
June White House Counsel done began
threatened to quit the president the
time said backed off back then Chris
ruddy a trump confidant told PBS the
president was considering it I think
he's considering perhaps terminating the
special counsel I think he's he's
weighing that option but by August mr.
Trump said removing Muller was far from
his mind from you people you say oh I'm
going to dismiss him no I'm not
dismissing anybody CBS News has learned
mr. Trump addressed conflict-of-interest
concerns about Muller with top advisors
among the issues a dispute over Muller's
membership fee at one of the president's
golf clubs work Muller had done at a law
firm that represented Jared Kushner and
that Muller had interviewed with mr.
Trump for the FBI director job a day
before being appointed special counsel
concern over Muller's fate was apparent
on Capitol Hill last summer any effort
to go after Muller could be the
beginning of the end
the Trump presidency and last night
lawmaker said Muller and his
investigation should be left alone if
it's true it would be concerning to me
there is a credible case of obstruction
of justice against the president United
States we have now a constitutional
crisis looming under the law President
Trump cannot fire Muller only deputy
attorney general rod Rosenstein can do
that and Rosen Stein has told Congress
he sees nothing wrong with Mahler's
approach to the Special Counsel
investigation and president Trump's
remarks earlier this week that he not
only looks forward to an interview with
Muller and he would do it under oath
John that suggests for now while his job
security is safe major thanks so much